[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جم
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من الخرطوم نتابع هذه الصور
المباشره مع اعلان الولايات المتحده
والسعوديه توصل الجيش والدعم السريع في
السودان الى هدنه تبدا الساعه السادسه من
صباح غدا ولمده 72 ساعه
ونتابع هذه الصور المباشره من كييف مع
اعلان القوات الاوكرانيه تقدمها فيزا
بروجيا وباخموت كييف تؤكد حاجتها لاسلحه
بعيده المدى وعاليه الدقه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
اعلان امريكي سعودي لوقت اطلاق النار بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع بدءا من
الغد ولمده ثلاثه ايام
وتلويح بتاجيل محادثات جده اذا خلقت
الهدنه النداءات لتدارك الازمه الانسانيه
تتزايد منظمات امميات توافق مقتل اكثر من
300 طفل ونزوح اكثر من مليون اخرين وقتل
ومئات الجرحى من بين الاف اللاجئين الذين
عبروا الحدود الى تشاد فارينا من معارك
غرب دارفور
القوات الاوكرانيه تقول انها تتقدم في
زابوريا وباخموت وموسكو تعلن صدها هجماتها
في خرسون
لن يرحبوا بمبادره السلام الافريقيه
ويستبعد امكانيه تطبيقها وقياس تصف كل
مبادرات السلام المعروضه لدعوات للاستسلام
وبعد اتجاه لتسريع انضمام اوكرانيا للنيتو
بايدن يرفض ويدعو للالتزام بمعايير الحلف
في اول زياره من نوعها منذ عقل وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه يبحث في طهران مع نظيره
الايراني استئناف العمل بالبعثات
الدبلوماسيه الامير فيصل بن فرحان يؤكد
اهميه التعاون الاقليمي بين دول المنطقه
وخلوها من اسلحه الدمار الشامل وعبد
اللهيان يقول انه سيتم تصديق على اسمي
سفيري البلدين مع تشكيل اللجنه سياسيه
واقتصاديه وحدوديه مشتركه
والرئيس الايراني يقول بعد استقبال وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه ان الخلافات في المنطقه
تحل بالحوار لا بالتدخل الاجنبي
قبيل زيارته الى الصين وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه طول انه يسعى لاقامه اتصالات
قويه مع بيجين ويبحث مع نظريه الياباني
والكوري الجنوبي سبل معالجه التوتر مع
كوريا الشماليه
وبايدن يعرب عن امله في لقاء نظيره الصيني
خلال اشهر لبحث العمل المشترك رغم الخلافه
في لقاءنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الوضع في دارفور الذي قد
يتحول لكارثه انسانيه قريبا وافتح تحذيرات
امميه فقد دعت الامم المتحده لايجاد حل
لما وصفته بالكابوس الذي يعيشه سكان اقليم
دارفور بينما اتهمت واشنطن قوات الدعم
السريع بارتكاب فضائح غرب الاقليم
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم هل تسرع
الماساه الانسانيه المتفاطمه في غرب
دارفور جهود حل ازمه السودان
25% قالوا انها ستسرع حل الازمه
40% قالوا انها لن يكون لها اي اثر اما
35% فراوا انها ستفاطم التداعيات الافوريه
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
ادانات دوليه لمقتل اكثر من 40 شخصا في
هجوم على مدرسه في غرب اوغندا وتساؤلات عن
نجاعه الجهود الاقليميه والدوليه لمواجهه
الحركات المسلحه في افريقيا
[موسيقى]
البدايه مشاهدينا من التطورات في السودان
حيث اعلنت المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه اتفاق ممثلي
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع على وقت اطلاق النار في جميع انحاء
السودان اعتبارا من السادسه صباحا من يوم
غد الاحد ولمده ثلاثه ايام واتفق الطرفان
على انهما خلال فتره وقف اطلاق النار
سيمتنعان عن التحركات والهجمات واستخدام
الطائرات الحربيه او القصف المدفعي او
تعزيز المواقع او اعاده امداد القوات كما
اتفقا على سماح بحريه الحركه وايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه في جميع انحاء
السودان
وقد حذر الوسيطان السعودي والامريكي حذر
الطرفين من عدم التزامهما بوقت اطلاق
النار وهو ما سيضطرهما الى النظر في تاجيل
محادثات جده وفق البيان الصادر عنهما
من جده ينضم الينا مراسله الجزيره بدر
ربيعان ومن واشنطن مراسل الجزيره محمد
العلمي ومن الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره مدير
مكتب الجزيره هناك المسلم الكباشي
والبدايه مع بدر الاربعاءان في
البيان الامريكي السعودي المشترك العديد
من النقاط هلا وضعتنا في ابرزها وكيف تم
التوصل الى وقف اطلاق النار هذا لمده
ثلاثه ايام
الواضح ان رعاه المبادره لازمه السودان
يحاولون الزام جانبي الصراع والنزاع
بالتزام بمخرجات اتفاق جدا الموقعه في
الحادي عشر من مايو والذي تم تسميته انذاك
بالاتفاق الانساني ويطلب من اطراف النزاع
مراعاه المعايير الدوليه التي تحمي
المدنيين المتواجدينة المناطق النزاع هذه
المباحثات التي تجري هنا ببساطه سعوديه
امريكيه ايضا يحضرها مبعوث الام للسودان
اضافه الى ممثل رباعيه الدوليه
وتاتي نتيجه جهد والماسي السعودي امريكي
بهدف وقف هذه الحرب المندلعه منذ ثلاثه
اشهر تقريبا والعوده الى الالتزام بمسار
عمليه تفاوضيه جاده لايقاف هذه الحرب
وايجاد عمليه استقرار في السودان جهد
سعودي
امريكي ننتقل الى محمد العلمي مراسله
الجزيره في واشنطن للحديث عن هذا الجهد
الامريكي الذي اثمر بالتعاون مع الجهد
السعودي
اتفاق لوقت اطلاق النار ولكن بماذا يختلف
ثلاثه ايام نعم ولكن بماذا يختلف عن
سابقته من الهدن والاتفاقات
لا يختلف كثيرا حصلنا لان ببساطه الولايات
المتحده لا تملك اي ادوات للضغط على
الفريقين المتحاربين او جزره لاقناعهما
بمكافات مستقبليه انهما قرر التعاون مع
اي هدنه حتى الان كان حظ الولايات المتحده
سيئه مع
الوسيط السعودي ايضا في حمل طرفين على
احترام الهدن السابقه وربما قد يكون افضل
حظا هذه المره واضح من البيان ان الجانبين
ناشد الطرفين المتقاتلين على
الانتباه والاحساس بالماسي التي تحل
بالمدنيين السودانيين خاصه المذابح التي
تتم فيه اقليم دارفور وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه قبل بضعه ايام قليله فقط اصدرت
بيانا قويه اللهجه حملت فيه كلا من الجيش
السوداني وقوات التدخل السريع او السريع
مسؤوليتها ما يحدث الجيش السوداني في
نظرها لم ينجح في حمايه المدنيين
السودانيين في حين حملت الجزء الاكبر من
مسؤوليه ما يقع في دارفور تحديدا لقوات
الدعم السريع لكن يبدو انها لم تياس او
حاولت ان تحافظ على شعره معاويه مع
الطرفين
ومناشده الحس الانساني في قائدي
المجموعتين
المتقاتلتين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع على الاقل الحرص على حياه وسلامه
المدنيين السودانيين والزمن وحده كفيل
بالتاكيد فيما اذا كانت هذه الهدنه وجهود
الطرفين الوسيطين ربما افضل هذه المره من
المرات السابقه كيف كانت اصداء هذا
الاعلان عن وقف لاطلاق النار جديد يبدا من
صباح الغد في الخرطوم المسلم الكباشي هل
من مواقف
صدرت بعد هذا الاعلان
ماذا يقول الطرفان بشان ما يجري حاليا على
المستوى الميداني
الارض وبالتالي ليس هنالك ما يؤكد خرقها
او الالتزام بها ولكن تلاحظ ان منذ اعلان
مبادئ جده 11 من الشهر الماضي كل التركيز
على البعد الانساني ولكن لم يتحقق شيء في
هذا الهدف البعد الانساني لا يزال الاوضاع
الانسانيه تتدهور باستمرار بل تتدهور كل
لحظه ولذلك الهدنه ركزت على الجانب
الانساني ولكن ليس معلوما ليس معروفا ان
تتحقق اهداف هذه الهدنه كما
فشلت في الهدن السابقه خاصه وان
ينظر الكثيرون الى الى
ضعفك جهود المبذول في تحقيق الهدف
الانساني خاصه كلما تعقد هذا الهدف
الانساني وكلما بعدت الفجوه بين تحقق
استجابه لهذا الهدف وبين الواقع الفظيع
الذي يعيشه كثير من اللاجئين والسودانيين
لاحظ الاخيره حسن هي ان شروط الهدن
السابقه بخروج القوات العسكريه من المشافي
ومن مساكن الناس والاحياء منذ الهدنه
السابقه وهذه الهدنه لم يشر لهذه لهذه
الشروط ربما ياسا من الطرف السوداني طرف
الجيش السوداني في عرضها او عجزا من عرضها
الوسطاء بها شكرا لك للمسلم الكباشي مدير
مكتب الجزيره من الخرطوم شكرا لمحمد
العلمي الذي كان معنا من واشنطن ولبدر عن
مراسل الجزيره كان معنا من جده
هذا وقد تواصلت اليوم المواجهات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في الخرطوم
وضواحيها وسمع ذوي المضادات الارضيه في
جنوب ام درمان ووسط وغرب الخرطوم بالتزامن
مع تحليق للطائرات الحربيه وافاد مراسل
الجزيره باستمرار تصاعدي سحب الدخان من
منطقه تقع فيها مخازن رئيسيه للوقود جنوبي
الخرطوم
يوم اخر في حرب الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع وضحايا جدد في مختلف اتجاهات
البلاد في الخرطوم تواصلت مواجهات
الجانبين وتحدث مراسل الجزيره عن استمرار
المعارك العنيفه الدائره بينهما والتصاعد
اعمده الدخان في منطقه اليرموك جنوب
الخرطوم وهي منطقه بها مخازن وقود رئيسيه
وافادت مصادر طبيه سودانيه بمقتل وجرح
العديد من المدنيين جراء القصف الكثيف
واخلائهم لاحد المستشفيات بينما اسفل
القصف عن تدمير كامل لعدد من المنازل في
هذه الاثناء وصف نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني مالك عقار خلال تصريحات في
القاهره وصف الوضع في السودان بانه كارثي
وان العاصمه الخرطوم تتعرض للدمار الكامل
وقال ان قوات الدعم السريع تحتل عددا من
المناطق السكنيه وتتخذ من المدنيين
الدروعا بشريه وشدد على ضروره انهاء الحرب
التي تشهدها البلاد منذ منتصف ابريل
الماضي بشرط ان يكون للسوداني جيش واحد في
هذه الاثناء تتواصل الاحداث الداميه في
منطقه الجنينه وافاد مراسل الجزيره بان
عشرات المدنيين الفارين والجرحى وبينهم
نساء واطفال يعبرون الحدود مع تشاد
ويتحدثون عن المع العنيفه الدائره في
المدينه وضواحيها وقد بث الناشطون صورا
قالوا انها لمسلحين يطاردون الفارين من
احداث الجنينه وينهبون ما يحملونه من متاع
ما فتيات الاوضاع في دارفور تثير قلقا
متزايدا بجانب تدهور الاوضاع الانسانيه
تقول الامم المتحده انما يشهده غرب
الاقليم قد يرقى لمستوى الجرائم ضد
الانسانيه
اشارت منظمه اطباء بلا حدود الى ان زهاء
سته الاف شخص فالروم من الجنينه خلال
الايام الماضيه مع تصاعد اعمال العنف هناك
وانما لا يقل عن 600 جريح ادخلوا مستشفى
ادريس خلال الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
واغلبيه اصاباتهم كانت جراء اطلاق النار
ووصف منسق المنظمه في ادري سيبو داريا
الوضع بانه يفوق طاقه المدينه
الثابت ان حرب الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع دخلت شهرها الثالث دون اي مؤشرات
لتوقفها بل تمددت واصبحت تحوم حول طرفيها
الاتهامات بانتهاك حقوق الانسان
انا هنا في الاستوديو ضياء الدين بلال
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني مرحبا بك
سيد ضياء الدين اذن الاعلان عن الاتفاق
لوقف اطلاق النار لمده ثلاثه ايام يبدا من
السادسه صباح الغد على ما يدل
او تدل موافقه الطرفين على ذلك هذه
الموافقه تكررت عدد من المرات ولكن من
المؤشرات الايجابيه ان الهدنه الاخيره
التي استمرت لمده 24 ساعه كانت الاستجابه
فيها عاليه خاصه فيما يتعلق بوقف اطلاق
النار والغرض الاساسي من هذه الهدى وقف
اطلاق النار وفتح المسارات الانسانيه
وهذا الامر اصبح ضروري الان بعد الازمات
الانسانيه الكبيره في الخرطوم وخاصه في
غرب السودان كذلك في غرب دارفور فمن
المرجح ان ترسم هذه الهدى في تليين
المواقف والتقريب ما بين الاطراف خاصه وان
حظوظ المبادره والمساعي السعوديه
الامريكيه تبدو اكبر من المثودات
الافريقيه
هنالك خصام وصراع بدا يظهر ما بين الاتحاد
الافريقي والايزاد فيما يتعلق بهذا الملف
فهذا رفع من قيمه
المبادره والمساعي السعوديه الامريكيه
تبدو ولكن يلاحظ ان هذه المساعي لا تخرج
عن هذا الاطار وهو اطار وقف اطلاق النار
وهدى انسانيه
لفترات قصيره لماذا لا نحدد الصراع
القائمه الان والطبيعه وتعقيدات الصراع لا
تسمح بان يكون هنالك خطوات اكثر ايجابيه
في هذا الامر الغرض الاساسي من هذه الهدن
هو محاوله للتليين هذه المواقف المتشدده
لجميع الاطراف ومن ثم يتم الانتقال الى
امر اخر متعلق بوقف الدائم باطلاق النار
ولكن في كل المرات السابقه كانت هذه الهدن
سرعان ما تفشل وسرعان ما ترتكب فيها
الكثير من التجاوزات خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالالتزام بالاعراف والقوانين المتعلقه
بقواعد الاشتباك المنظمه عبر المنظمه قبل
عبر القانون الدولي
مع عامل الزمن اعتقد ان يمكن ان تكون
هنالك حظوظ اكبر لهذه المساعي عندما لا
يتم الالتزام بالهدى
عموما باستثناء ربما الهدنه الاخيره
هل معنى ذلك بان تلك الموافقه التي تحظى
بها الجهود الامريكيه السعوديه لوقت اطلاق
النار انما هي من ضمن العلاقات العامه
اكثر مما هي موافقه حقيقيه تترجم على
الارض وقتا لاطلاق النار هذا جانب يمكن ان
يؤخذ بالاعتبار ولكن هنالك امر اخر يجب
النظر اليه كذلك بيديها وهو النوبات الدعم
السريعي الى حد كبير جدا فقدت القياده
التحكميه والسيطره من قبل من قبل قياده
الدعم السريع واصبحت كثير من الاعمال التي
تتم تخرج عن الاوامر
العلويه التي تاتي من قياده من القياده
العليا واصبحت هذه المجموعات خاصه
المنتشره في الخرطوم تتحرك وفق الاجنده
الاجنده الشخصيه المباشره المتعلقه بالنعب
والسلب والاعتداء على المواطنين وغير ذلك
وكذلك ما يحدث في في غرب دارفور وهو
يتحرك وف بمعطيات الصراع القبلي في في
المنطقه فهذا الواقع المعقد المرتبط
بالدعم السريع هو الذي يسهم في افشال كل
الهدن السابقه ولكن يعني على المستوى
الميداني كما هو واضح بان قوه الدعم
السريع ما زالت تسيطر على العديد من
الاماكن والعديد من المواقع
وانها تعمل ايضا وفق خطه منهجيه عسكريه
بدليل ما ما حصل اليوم من اسقاط طائره
وغير ذلك نعم هذا مرتبط بمجموعه محدوده في
الدعم السريع هنالك مجموعه محدوده لا تزال
ملتزمه باوامر القياده وهي فاعله في
العمليات العسكريه ومؤثره كذلك خاصه حينما
دخلت المسيرات في الصراع ولكن لا نستطيع
ان نقول بان الدعم السريع يسيطر الدعم
السريع ينتشر في مساحات واسعه
موجود في بعض المناطق التي كان في حمايتها
في البدايه وهي مثل القصر الجمهوري
والاذاعه وغير ذلك فالانتشار
الكبير لا يقول بان هنالك سيطره لان
المقرات قد ضربت بالان لم تعد هنالك اماكن
لايواء القوات فالتجات الى الاحتمال
بالمواطنين كديروع بشريه وانتشار واسع
وهذا ما يطرح سؤالا عن سبب عدم الحسم اذا
في في هذه الحاله اشكرك سيدي الدين بلال
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني
الاف اللاجئين السودانيين
يصلون الى هنا في هذه المنطقه
الحدوديه
بتات فرينا من
الجنينه بعضهم شيوخ ومرضى وكثير من
الاطفال الذين قطعوا المسافه من الجنينه
الى الحدود الشاديه في ادره وهي
نحو 25
كيلومترا قطعوها مشيا على
الاقدام هربا من
الحروب التي
ما زالت متواصله في
الجنانه عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور يشتكي
اللاجئون من انهم
يواجهون صعوبات بالغه في الطريق هناك عده
مسلحين يطلقون النار على
الفرينه من مدينه الجنينه بحسب ما
يقوله
الفارونه من المدينه ولكن هذا اليوم ومنذ
الصباح
بدا اللاجئون يتدفقون
بكثره الى هذه المنطقه طابور طويل الى
داخل الاراضي السودانيه
ببلده اديكون
ومنها الى
العمق في ولايه غرب دارفور كلهم يحاولون
الوصول الى تشاد هربا من الحرب في ولايه
غربي دارفور فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره
الحدود التجاديه السودانيه
[موسيقى]
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اكد
قائد القوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه عمليات
تافريا جنوب شرق اوكرانيا تحقيق تقدم على
طول الجبهه التي تشمل جنوب مقاطعتي
سبولوجيا ودونيسك واعلن المسؤول العسكري
استهداف نحو
1800 هدف خلال يوم واحد ما اسفر عن مقتل
وجرح افراد من خمس سرايا من الجيش الروسي
وتدمير اكثر من 80 اليه عسكريه كما افادت
القوات الاوكرانيه
بتحقيق اختراق لتحصينات الروسيه في منطقه
هذا واعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تدمير
احد مراكز صنع القرار التابع للقوات
الاوكرانيه بضربه شنتها عبر البحر والجو
وقال المتحدث باسم الوزاره ان قوات بلاده
صدت عشره هجمات اوكرانيه في اتجاه
كما اعلن حكام مقاطعات بلجورود وبريانسكو
تعرضها لقصف اوكراني من جهتي ان نشرت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه صورا قالت انها
لتدمير احد معاقل القوات الاوكرانيه جنوب
دونتسك واضافت الوزاره ان القوات الروسيه
قصفت بمسيره احد معاقل القوات الاوكرانيه
اسلحه مضاده للدبابات
وقال نائب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
لوف ان قواتهم تنتهز حاليا فرصه الهجوم
وتمركز القوات الروسيه دفاعيا واشار في
تصريحات نشرت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه الى
حاجه باسلحه طويله المدى وعاليه الدقه
لتحقيق النصر على الروس واضاف جافري لوف
ان اوكرانيا في طريقها للحصول على طائرات
ستدافع بشكل اساسي عن اجوائها ضد الصواريخ
الباليستيه الروسيه وغيرها من الصواريخ
حسب تعبيره
سياسيا اجرى وفد الوساطه الافريقيه
محادثات مع الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين في
مدينه سامبوتسبورغ بعد يوم من زيارتك
ولقاء الرئيس الينسكي وخلال الاجتماع اكد
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين انفتاحه على
اجراء حوار بناء مع كل من يريدون السلام
من جهه جدد مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
ميخائيل رفض بلاده للمبادره الافريقيه وكل
الوسطات السابقه لانها تريد استسلام
اوكرانيا وليس السلام على حد تعبيره في
الاثناء قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان
بلاده لن تسهل انضمام اوكرانيا للنيتو ما
لم تلبى المعايير الخاصه بالحلف على غرار
الدول الاعضاء الاخرى
في عاصمه روسيا القيصريه سابقا حل الوفد
الافريقي الوسيط للقاء الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين بعد يوم من زياره للعاصمه كييف
والاستماع الى رفض الرئيس زيلينسكي
التفاوض مع موسكو الحكم الغربي المسبق
بفشل المبادره الافريقيه لانهاء الحرب
التي تهز اوروبا لم يمنع القاده من مواصله
رحلتهم ولقاءاتهم مع طرفي النزاع
المباشرين روسيا واوكرانيا لم يسمع الضيوف
كلاما جديدا لافسا ولا فيكييف عن شروط كل
طرف للحوار ووقف القتال لكن الرئيس بوتين
اشاد بمقاربه متوازنه للدول الافريقيه
بشان حرب اوكرانيا
نحن منفتحون على اجراء حوار بناء مع كل من
يريدون السلام على اساس مبادئ العداله
ومراعاه المصالح المشروعه للطرفين تنص
المبادره الافريقيه على انسحاب القوات
الروسيه وازاله الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه
من بيلاروسيا وتعليق مذكره التوقيف
الصادره من المحكمه الجنائيه بحق الرئيس
بوتين ما يسمح بتوفير البيئه المناسبه
لوقف اطلاق النار حتى قبل ان تبدا صرح
حلفاء اكياف ان الوساطه الافريقيه هي
الاضعف وبان فرص فشلها هي الاكبر بيد ان
موسكو تنظر الى هؤلاء بشكل مختلف من منطلق
تغيير التحالفات وجذب اطراف جديده الى
المعسكرات التي افرزتها حسابات الحرب
العابره للقارات
باجنداتها المختلفه موقف كياف من الوساطه
الاخيره والتي سبقتها سلبي انها لا تريد
السلام لاوكرانيا بل الاستسلام هكذا وصفها
مستشار الرئيس زيلينسكي
هم لا يعرضون خطه للسلام بل يعرضون
استسلام اوكرانيا كل هذه الخطط
الاندونيسيه والافريقيه والصينيه
والبرازيليه واي مبادره سوف نسمعها غير
صيغه السلام الاوكرانيه التي توضح بشكل
عملي ودقيق الطريق الى السلام ليست خطط
سلام بل هي دعوات لاستسلام اوكرانيا
دعوات اوكرانيا لانضمامها سريعا الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي طلب بعيد المنال كلام الرئيس
الامريكي بايدن يعكس الموقف المعروف عن
الانقسام داخل الحلف بشان مساله تعجيل
الانضمام التي تعارضها واشنطن والمانيا
والمجر
د
ينبغي ان تنطبق عليهم المعايير نفسها هذا
يعني اننا لن نسهل امرا انضمام البلد الذي
يواجه هجوما عسكريا روسيا لا مشكله في
تقديم دعم عسكري غير مسبوق للقوات
الاوكرانيه لكن الالتحاق بالنيتو واحتمال
تفعيل البند الخامس قضيه اخرى تستدعي
تريثا لا يعجبك
على ارض المعركه يسعى كل طرف لتحقيق مكاسب
عسكريه او على الاقل الحفاظ على ما تحقق
لضمان اوراق ضغط اكبر في حال التفاوض
المؤجل الى حين تتحدث كياف عن تقدم في
المراحل الاولى لهجومها المضاد تحديدا في
الجنوب وموسكو تقول انها دمرت احد مراكز
صنع القرار للقوات الاوكرانيه والتصدي
لهجوم على مصفاه للنفط في بريوسك الحرب
والسلام مفردتان يبدو ان لم يحن بعد
لتشتمع معا هنا السلاح فقط هو اللغه
التخاطب بين روسيا واوكرانيا
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
نورس والباحث في قضايا الامن الدوليه كذلك
معنا من موسكو ديمتري بابيتش الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي ونبدا معك سيد
ابراهمز الرئيس الامريكي حسمها على
اوكرانيا ان تلبي معايير الحلف ولكن
لماذا جرى الحديث في اليومين الماضيين عن
ان هناك مساعن
وقبولا حتى امريكيا
لتسريع انضمام اوكرانيا للنيتو
ليس واضحا تماما بالنسبه الى المهله
الزمنيه والاطار الزماني لانضمام اوكرانيا
الى حلف النيتو فهذا امر جرى تداوله منذ
فتره طويله اعتقد ان اداره بايدن تريد
الدخول اوكرانيا الحلف ولكن من جهه اخرى
لا تريد دخولها مباشره لان اوكرانيا في
خدم حرب وهناك تفاهم بان اوكرانيا سوف لن
تنضم الى الحلف وهي في خدم حرب كذلك هناك
فتره
معهوده للتقييم حيث تنتظر كل دوله من اجل
ان تقيم من اجل ان تحسن سجلها مثلا في
مجال مكافحه الفساد ما قاله الرئيس بايدن
هو ان هذه العمليه
نفسها للتحقق من استيفاء المعايير يجب ان
تنطبق وسوف تنطبق على اوكرانيا من جهه
اخرى هناك دول اخرى اعضاء في الحلف غير
سعيده بهذه العمليه وهي تضغط على العاصمه
واشنطن من اجل تسريع المهله الزمنيه
وبالتالي ليست فقط مساله عمل واشنطن
لوحدها بدون تشاور وهنا ولكن هناك مفاوضات
بين الدول الاعضاء في الحلف من اجل اتخاذ
قرار حول هذا الاطار الزماني
سيدي ابراهامز عفوا السيد ابراهيم من من
هي الدول من هي الدول باختصار فقد سمي لنا
الدول من الناتو التي تضغط باتجاه تسريع
دخول اوكرانيا الى الناتو من هي هذه الدول
التي تضغط على واشنطن في هذا الموضوع
[موسيقى]
سوف يتضح الامر اكثر لان هناك اجتماع وشيك
سوف يعقد ولكن بصوره عامه نتحدث عن دول
مثل بولندا دول البلطيق هذه الدول تريد ان
تدعم اوكرا اكثر وهي اكثر نشاطا اكثر
تصعيدا هي لا يهمها فعلا ان تستفز روسيا
وهي تريد تقصير المهله الزمنيه لدخول
اوكرانيا الحلف
سيد بابيتش
كيف برايك تتلقى موسكو هذه المواقف
الامريكيه والتي على رغم كل هذا الدعم
العسكري الا انها تبقي على بعض الحواجز
منها نوعيه الاسلحه
الهجوميه لاوكرانيا التي لم تسلم حتى الان
والموقف من دخولها الى الناتو وهو ما حسمه
الرئيس بايدن اليوم
في الحقيقه تنظر موسكو الى هذه التطورات
والى هذه التصريحات بطريقه هادئه لا
شعور بان هناك توتر لان الوضع ليس بجديد
في الحقيقه
بحكم الواقع كانت اوكرانيا ستتحول الى او
سوف تدخل الحلف بين 2014 والى 2022 حتى
بدا ما يسمى بالعمليه العسكريه من قبل
روسيا وهي اسمرار للحرب هي ليست حربا
جديده هي استمرار للحرب التي بدات في
اوكرانيا في 2014
بعد
العمليات العنيفه التي حصلت من قبل دول
الغرب لاطاحه الرئيس اذا الدوله
كانت في حرب منذ 8 سنوات وموسكو انضمت
العاده الحرب هذه السنه في العام 2021
كانت بريتانيا قد اقامت مركزا تدريبيا في
جنوب
اوكرانيا اثار الشقوق بانه يشبه مقر
النيتو حتى ان اوكرانيا استخدمت قبل الحلف
من اجل جمع القوى الدوده الروسيا اذا قرار
بوتين التدخل وبدا هذه التحركات العسكريه
في فبراير السنه الماضيه
املته اذا فكره ان اوكرانيا اصلا كانت
بحكم الواقع كانت تتحول الى عضو في الحلف
بدون الضمانات الامنيه التي تترافق مع ذلك
اذا هي في الثمانينيات استخدمت المتحده
الدول الافريقيه
كدمى من اجل مواجهات الاتحاد السوفيتي
واوكرانيا هذه المره مثلها هي دفعت الثمن
شكرا جزيلا لك دبي 3 بابيتش من موسكو
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وشكرا لماكس
ابرامز استاذه العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
نورس ايسون كان معنى من بوستون
[موسيقى]
اجرى وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير
عبد اللهيان مباحثات مع نظير السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان الذي وصل اليوم الى
طهران وتعد هذه اول زياره من نوعها بعد
اتفاق الطرفين في مارس اذار الماضي على
استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بينهما
وقالت الخارجيه السعوديه ان الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ونظيره الايراني امير عبداللهيان
ناقشات عزيزه تنسيق في عدد من القضايا
الاقليميه والدوليه
واكد وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل
بن فرحان على اهميه التعاون الاقليمي بين
دول المنطقه وخلوها من اسلحه الدمار
الشامل
نشير الى اهميه
بين بلدينا فيما يتعلق بالامن الاقليمي
لاسيما امن الملاحه البحريه
واهميه التعاون بين جميع دول المنطقه
لضمان خلويها من جميع اسلحه الدمار الشامل
من جهه قال وزير الخارجيه لرني حسين امير
عبد الله انه سيتم التصديق على اسمي سفيري
البلدين مع تشكيل لجنه سياسيه واقتصاديه
وحدوديه مشتركه مشيرا الى انه ناقش مع
نظير السعودي مختلفه ابعاد العلاقات
الايرانيه السعوديه
[تصفيق]
تحدثنا عن الامن الاقليمي من خلال تعاون
متعدد الجوانب اود ان اؤكد ان الامن
الاقليمي وامن كل بلد من بلدان المنطقه
امر اساسي ومصري وضروره لا يمكن انكارها
لتحقيق مستقبل اكثر امانا وازدهارا في
منطقتنا المشتركه جمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه
لا تعتبر ابدا الامن مرادفا للتسلح بل
للامن مفهوم شامل يتضمن ابعادا سياسيه
وثقافيه واجتماعيه واقتصاديه وتجاريه بين
دول المنطقه
هذا والتقى الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس
في طهران وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان وقال الرئيس الايراني ان
الخلافات في المنطقه تحل بالحوار وليس
بالتدخل الاجنبي وعرب رئيسي عن ترحيبه
باستئناف العلاقات مع السعوديه وقال ان
اعداء الدول الاسلاميه على راسهم اسرائيل
غاضبون من تحسين العلاقات بين البلدين
تصريحه المسؤولين السعوديين والايرانيين
تاتي تتويجا لمسار من الترتيبات اخذت
اعلان بيجين في مارس اذار الماضي
القاضي بعوده العلاقات بينهما سياق التطور
العلاقات نتابعه في العرض التالي
هي اول زياره لوزير خارجيه سعودي لايران
منذ اكثر من عقد من الزمن تفاؤل معلن من
الطرفين ازاء تطبيع العلاقات بين بلديهما
ورفع مستواها لكن مسار استعاده العلاقه
بين البلدين بدا بتحرك وساطات حيث نجح
العراق وعمان في عقد اجتماعات مشتركه
لمسؤولين ايرانيين والسعوديين خلال
العامين الماضيين وتوجت هذه اللقاءات
بتوقيع اتفاق عوده العلاقات في بيجين في
العاشر من مارس اذار الماضي وفي السادس من
ابريل نيسان وقع وزير الخارجيه في بيجين
بيانا مشتركا بشان تنفيذ الاتفاق الذي
توصل اليه البلدان تضمن البيان اتخاذ
الاجراءات لفتح سفرتي البلدين في الرياض
وطهران وقنصليه جده ومشهد كما اكد
الجانبان على تفعيل اتفاقيه التعاون
الامني والاتفاقيه ذات الطابع الاقتصادي
زارت وفود كلا من الرياض والظهران لوضع
خطط لاعاده فتح السفارات والممثلات
الدبلوماسيه
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن انه اجرم مباحثات مع نظريه
الياباني والكوري الجنوبي تتعلق بالتحديات
الاقليميه والعالميه بما فيها الخطوات
الخطيره التي تقوم بها كوريا الشماليه
لزعزعه الاستقرار واطلاق الصواريخ
البالستيه وعشيه زياره الوزير الامريكي
الى العاصمه الصينيه بجين اعرب الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن عن امله في اجراء لقاء
مع نظيره الصيني خلال الاشهر المقبله
نقلت وسائل الاعلام يونانيه ان عمليات
البحث عن ناجين والمفقودين من حدث غرق
قارب كان يقل اعدادا كبيره من طالب اللجوء
قباله سواحل اليونان ستتوقف غدا الاحد
بسبب تلاشي الامان بالعثور على نجينا جدد
وقالت وزاره الملاحه اليونانيه ان احد
المعتقلين المصريين اعترف بمشاركته في
تنظيم الرحله التي تسببت في غرق المركب
وافاد المصدر نفسه بان سبعه معتقلين اخرين
يحملون الجنسيه المصريه نفى انتمائهم الى
شبكه الهجره السريه التي نظمت هذه الرحله
ودافعت اداره خثر السواحل اليونانيه عن
ادارتها لهذه الازمه التي باتت توصف بثاني
اسوا حادث غرق تشهده منطقه البحر الابيض
المت
وسط من جهه المنظمه الدوليه للهجره
ومفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
الاتحاد الاوروبي التيخاذ اجراءات عاجله
وحازمه للحد من تزايد الوفيات الناتجه عن
حوادث الغرق في البحر المتوسط
انتشر على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي خلال
ساعات القليله الماضيه فيديو مروع يوافق
حادثه جلدي عدد من المسلمين امام احد
المساجد في مدينه
جوناجاد بولايه غجرات شماليه الهند يوم
امس
ويظهر في الفيديو المتداول عدد من الاشخاص
يقفون امام المسجد بينما يقوم مول الثمان
بجلدهم وصه علي صرخات المعتدى عليهم ولكن
دون ان يتوقفوا عن جلدهم وقد وقعت حادثه
الجلد عطيبه احتجاج تقلل اشتباك عنيف بين
المئات من المسلمين مدينه وافراد الشرطه
بسبب اعتراض المجتمع المسلم في المدينه
على بدء السلطات المحليه هدم مسجد ومقبره
اسلاميه زعمت حكومه المدينه انها مبنيه
على ارض مملوكه للحكومه
[موسيقى]
مع حلول فصل الصيف بدا شبح الجفاف في
فرنسا يلوح في الافق مره اخرى فبعد شتاء
جاف تراجع منسوب المياه الجوفيه
وصنفت 30 مقاطعه ضمن المناطق المهدده
بالجفاف حتى قبل بدايه فصل الصيف
كاقرانه المزارعين يترقب برينو بصبر نافذ
الامطار هذه الايام فالمناخ الجاف السائد
منذ اشهر بدا يتهدد كلما زرعه يخفي بصعوبه
شعوره بالياس بينما يتفقد مزرعته فالتربه
تبدو صلبه كالحجر
خسرنا من خمسه مليمترات من الامطار الى
سته يوميا لدينا جفاف مرئي على سطح هنا
نرى كيف ان الارض اصبحت صلبه نتيجه لذلك
سيتاخر نمو النباتات فمثلا الشمندرت اثر
كثيرا عند اقتلاعه في اكتوبر سيكون بهذا
الحجم الصغير جدا
[موسيقى]
بعد شتاء جاف لم تحسن امطار الربيع الوضع
في مزرعه جون كلود ولولا سقيو ما كانت
لتخرج بعض النباتات
المفارقه ان السلطات ابلغته بانها ستقنن
له استخدام مياه
السقيط
مع الايام المقبله لا يسمح لي بالسقي خلال
النهار ساكون مجبرا على السقي ليلا بكميات
قليله واذا منعونا فلن نستطيع زرع اي شيء
والسكان لا يجد ما يؤكل
وفق خبراء مناخ فان هذا الجفاف مقدمه لما
قد تشهده فرنسا خلال العام الجاري وربما
مستقبلاط المياه ستكون السلطات مجبره على
منح الاولويه اما للانتاج الزراعي واما
للصناعات او اعطاء الاولويه لمياه الشرب
وهذا سيؤدي الى توترات وربما لنشوب نزاعات
من اجل المياه في اوروبا ومناطق اخرى من
العالم
فرنسا كانت شهدت العام الماضي واحده من
اسوا موجات الجفاف وهذا العام يتوقع
المزارعون خسائر قياسيه بعد فصل الشتاء
قليل الامطار جاء وقته ترشيد استخدام
المياه فالجفاف بدا يمتد الى مناطق كثيره
في فرنسا وسط توقعات بان يتغير الواقع
الزراعي للبلاد اذا تكررت موجات الجفاف
نور الدين بوزيان الجزيره شمال فرنسا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا فقره في المتابعه هذه الليله
نسلط فيها الضوء على مقتل اكثر من اربعين
شخصا واصابه عشرات في هجوم استهدف مدرسه
في مدينه بويره الاوغنديه الشرطه وصفت
الهجوم بالارهابي واتهمت من سمتهم متمردي
تحالف القوه الديمقراطيه باحراق مرقد
للطلاب في المدينه
بحسب ارقام مجموعه بيانات مواقع النزاع
المسلح فقد زادت احداث العنف المرتبطه
بنشاطات الجماعات المسلحه في افريقيا
بنسبه
22% ويتركز العنف في خمس مناطق رئيسيه في
افريقيا وهي الساحل الافريقي والصومال
وحوض بحيره تشاد
وموزمبيق وشمال افريقيا
وشهدت منطقتها الساحل والصومال سبعه
وسبعين في المئه من اجمالي احداث العنف
المبلغ عنها في جميع انحاء القاره خلال
عام
2022 وفي منطقه غرب الساحل التي تضم
بوركينا فاسو ومالي وغرب النيجر وقع اكثر
من
2700 هجوم لتصبح اكبر منطقه تشهد وهجمات
مسلحه خلال العام الماضي بينما حلت منطقه
حوض بحيره تشاد في الترتيب كفاله اكثر
المناطق فتكا في القاره السمراء حيث تضم
20% من جميع القتلى المرتبطين بعنف
الجماعات المسلحه
هذه الارقام تطرح تساؤلات بشان النجاعه
الجهود الاقليميه والدوليه في مواجهه
الحركات المسلحه بالقاره ولكن نتعرف اولا
على بعض هذه الجود
عمليه
برخان لمكافحه النشاط المسلح في منطقه
الساحل الغربي الافريقي والتي اعلن الرئيس
الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون انتهائها في نوفمبر
العام الماضي
بعثه الامم المتحده المتكامله المتعدده
الابعاد لتحقيق الاستقرار في مالي والتي
انشئت في ابريل عام 2013
تمركز خمس بعثات للاتحاد الاوروبي معنيه
بالتصدي للعمليات المسلحه في النيجر ومالي
والصومال
وفي موزمبيق دعت الحكومه مستشارين عسكريين
امريكيين لدعم قواتها المسلحه في مواجهه
المسلحين
للمزيد حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
نواكشوت
الهبه ولد الشيخ سيدتي الكاتب الصحفي
المتخصص في الشان الافريقي والجماعات
المسلحه في افريقيا مرحبا بك سيدي ليبا
يعني كل هذه الجهود التي ذكرناها والحملات
لوقف عنف الجماعات المسلحه في افريقيا
يبدو انها
لم تؤدي الى النتيجه المرجوه او المتوخات
لماذا
مرحبا واهلا الهجوم الذين ذكرتهم اليوم في
اوغندا هو على بعد اثنين كيلو متر من
الناحيه الجغرافيه من الكونغو وهذه
المنطقه في الفعل تنشط فيها القوات
المسلحه المتحالفه وازيد من 100 جماعه
مسلحه حتى ذات تصنيف الغربي
وهذه الجماعه تنشط منذ ازيد من 28 عاما
وجهودها واعمالها في كل مره بازدياد ورغم
ما يسميه الولايات المتحده بالحصار
وبالعقوبات وحتى الوجود العسكري كما
تعلمون في قبل اشهر من ابريل الماضي حصل
هناك
قرارات من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مثل
هديه
مكافاه ماليه لمن كشف او اعطاه معلومات عن
قاده هذه الجماعات عقوبات على بعضها وهذه
هي العقوبات المتخذه حتى الان ضد هذه
الجماعات وهي عقوبات طريفه فكان النظام
المالي الامريكي الخزانه الامريكيه
لديها لديها هؤلاء حسابات لديها او كانهم
معنيون بها او كانهم اصلا
معلوماتهم توفر لهذه الجماعات هذه الجهود
كلها التي تعبر عن الوجود الافريقي في
المنطقه الوجود الغربي في المنطقه هو في
الاساس يخدم او تتخادم حتى لا اقول يدعم
بشكل مباشر هناك جهود نزلات تتخادم في هذه
المنطقه الافريقيه ادت للعنف الكبير فيها
هذه الثلاثي الاضلاع هو المعروف بالغزاه
والغلاه
سيدي
الغلاف هذه الجماعات مثلا بهجوم على مدرسه
بما انك اخذت هذا الموضوع كمثال بالهجوم
على هذه المدرسه ماذا ماذا تستفيد هذه
الجماعات او ماذا تقدم من رسائل من خلال
ذلك عندما يقتل اربعون تلميذا او طفلا
هذه الجماعات
هدفها وايديولوجيتها هي صناعه الرعب صناعه
الخوف الاضرار بما امكن من يتم من اضرار
هذا معروف وهذا موجود لكن السؤال الذي
طرحتم وهو سؤال جوهري وجدي اين حمايه
المدنيين اين الجهود الامميه والقوات
الدوليه اين الجهود العربيه لمكافحه
التطرف اين هذه الاموال الطائله التي تنفق
والعتاد العسكري والقوات المشتركه التي
تشكل من هنا وهناك هذا هو اللي يوقفي قتل
الابرياء لوقف تمدد هذه القوات الارهابيه
في هذه المنطقه لوقف العنف لوقف جماعات
التطرف هناك تخادم هذه الاسلحه لبعض
الاحيان في احيان كثيره بعض هذه الاسلحه
يذهب الى هذه الجماعات وبعضها هناك
تمويلات تذهب اليه وهناك فيديو تدفعها
الدول الغربيه لهذه الجماعات وبالتالي
فعلا هناك تخادم بين هذه الجماعات والغرب
والهدف للاسف هم سكان هذه المنطقه
الابرياء الاطفال
في الامنين في حجرات التدريس كما حصل الان
في اوغندا طيب اهداف هذه الجماعات ما هي
اهدافها المعلنه والغريب انك تضع كل هذه
الحملات من اجل وقف حد لعنف هذه الجماعات
تضعه في سياق ما يخدمها اكثر مما يضرها
صحيح انا قلت لك ان هناك تخادم تخادم في
هذه الجماعات والدليل واضح انا نحن مثلا
عندنا في السياسه الغربيه بالولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التي اصبحت سياسه
عالميه بعد احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
سنه 2001 لنبحث الان بعد كل هذه السياسات
ما التي تحقق لدى هذه الجماعات متى ما هو
انتشارها كانت جماعات محدوده في افغانستان
الان في القارات الخمس الان الجهود التي
كانت تبذل للمحاربه
[موسيقى]
تضاعفت وجودها الجغرافي تضاعف اعداده
منتسبيها تضاعفوا اذا هذه السياسه ينبغي
ان تقومها سياسه باسله كيف نفسر هذه
السياسه ان لم تكون خدمه لهؤلاء هذا تخادم
واضح وبين على الاقل لم تكن سياسه فاعله
فعاله بل هي سياسه سهامه بانتشار هذا
الفكر بانتشار هذا القتل بانتشارها هذا
واضح دول العظماء كلها مسؤوله عن هذه
السياسه
الهبه ولد الشيخ سيداتي الكاتب الصحفي
المتخصص في الشان الافريقي والجماعات
المسلحه في افريقيا شكرا لك حدثتنا من
مشاهدينا بهذا ننهي حصاد هذه الليله
تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]